do I look young and fun as I am not know
I'm nervous nobody no no you know your
life is different now welcome to my
youtube channel I do a lot of fashion
review videos I haven't done one in a
little bit and so why not come back with
the fashion review of the Kids Choice
Awards
cuz there's nothing more fun than
watching on YouTube and an adult
critique children clothing yep
everything's good let's look at the red
carpet fashions at the Kids Choice
Awards I feel we are doing this but
we're doing this Heidi Klum we're just
starting right off with the person that
I cared about being there the most Heidi
Klum one so glad that she made to the
lower half is a very like my kids made
this for me as an early Mother's Day
present and the upper half is like I'm
still not over Adam rip on not winning
and Sochi figure skating tribute kind of
thing yeah Milly Bobby Brown I think
that this girl is incredible even if she
is dating Jacob yeah I love and she's
even more incredible because this outfit
honored the victims of the Parkland
school shooting which on the weekend of
March for our lives was extremely
poignant and important and it was really
wonderful to see a young person not
being afraid send a message to be
involved and to use her platform so
Millie Bobby Brown once again I tip
another gosh dang hat to you for being
do you ever sleep cuz you're so woke oh
I'm so old Kendall McLaughlin another a
young actor on the stranger things cast
always looks so god dang cool this is
like mafia tracksuit meets Steve Jobs
Pharrell 2058 like you're living on a
different fashion platform than I am at
a fashion platform that I can't even
aspire to because aspiring to something
means that you think you could get there
no this is just like out of reach so
kudos maybe that's why I did not want to
review the Kids Choice Awards because it
would just be too direct
of a statement that they're just so good
dorm Reid who is in a wrinkle in time if
you have not seen it I this how how are
you this fashionable and put together
perfect just a little human Baba I'm
broken this is so cool
also your toenails look like you take
care of them and I ate two this day
don't even know how to take care of my
toenails so you're already like so far
ahead of the game this looks phenomenal
great job great job great job painting
list this looks like you are making a
list it looks like you're taking name
you look like a badass [ __ ] I didn't
mean to call you a [ __ ] at all
whatsoever I meant that in the highest
regard in that you look like a badass
you look great and powerful and strong
and confident and good job
you're our Shahidi this is so cute and
elegant it's very Shirley Temple meets
modern day and that might be the most
advanced fashion parallel I've ever made
should I quit while I'm ahead
no let's bulldoze through this also
you're wearing like seven-inch heels and
you're like maybe 17 we're okay good job
it's very impressive Chloe Kim US
Olympic snowboarder extraordinaire look
she get yourself a girl that can do both
like dominate effortlessly in
snowboarding and then wear frills like
this and be like oops
you're like a transformer but like one
that I want to be friends but Jaden
Smith yes layers more Jaden Smith's
aesthetic it is modern-day
Broadway musical Rent and I'm here for
it Jada Smith aesthetic is I'm going to
win if we play strip poker I have so
many layers you cannot defeat me I
probably shouldn't say strip poker in a
video about your viewing kids choice
work fashion stuff that's good say vsync
also from stranger things this is their
Wednesday from The Addams Family on a
Friday night meets like high powered CEO
with a book club for women than only on
motorcycles great job you killed it
Hailee Steinfeld steam just turns teen
thing for something what is this magic
act of a outfit you look like a
magician's assistant that it was in the
middle of one of those tablecloth pulls
and then you got oh distracted because
someone wanted your attention the
tablecloth got stuck in your pants and
made it work also you were having a
appendix corruption in the most
fashionable way possible q Brian Carey
and her daughter Monroe
this is a cheat is that let me they told
me there would be tea day yeah oh you ha
she knows how to when you think she's
gonna come cool hip modern this is like
Breakfast at Tiffany's but I mean like
your friend Tiffany who makes you
breakfast after you've done a walk of
shame that's also not an appropriate
reference for this sort of event I'm
sorry Kate Middleton but the United
States is now proven we have our own
princess in our miss our DIY it warms my
god damn metal heart when I see you do
purse on carpets for any award show
you're like a sexy female gladiator and
I'm here for it good job girl John Cena
who as I think the host of the Kids
Choice Awards and I can't say anything
about this I have definitely worn some
sort of variation of this at some point
in my professional life yeah this is
like looking into a mirror Kristen Bell
you look like a high fashion third
grader that's going on for her first day
of like fashion elementary school cute
by the Koshi yes makes me so happy
you're doing this cute red satin shorts
suit you had a cool blackjack dealer
super hip real estate agent you're like
I'm here for fun but also business if
the monopoly man was updated and made
into a woman it should be this was
putting it out there
Parker ballinger my heart is gasping and
we think it's sobbing and screaming
Colleen ballinger AKM Rena Singh's
nephew walk the red carpet as Miranda
sings and listen I I this is what the
world needs it's Parker you do not
understand what joy and promise and hope
you bring to a world that needs it the
most right now thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you for this okay
that is my record view of the Kids
Choice we're phantoms let me know in the
comments below you loved at the Kids
Choice Awards and what sort of fashion
reviews I should do in the future I'm
open leave it in the comments down below
also do not forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel and click thumbs up and
also the bail notification cuz I'm
trying to make videos Tuesday Thursday
but hey
that was my impression of the bonds
which is a reference that is I'll pick
it up cause it just went over your head
I don't know great job great job
also you're thrown out like everyone
there they get the pedicure say I'll get
pedicures and that's great
good job you guys